The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Hello.
So welcome to the
last lecture in 003.
So there are more
lectures scheduled.
But I don't believe
in trying to cram
new material in the last couple
of hours before the exam.
So no new material after today,
although it will be helpful
if you continue to try
to work on problems,
and try to internalize
what we did more recently.
That's the idea.
So I'm not trying to
pump new information in.
That doesn't mean that
there aren't things
that you should be doing.
But after today,
no new information.
In fact, today there
is no new information.
There will be a
session on Tuesday.
But the idea is primarily to
get feedback from you people.
As I mentioned last time,
we've changed a lot of things.
We change a lot of
things every term.
And our primary
source of information
is the end of term surveys.
Tell us what works.
Tell us what didn't work.
Tell us what you liked.
Tell us what you didn't like.
If you didn't like the
electronic submission
of homework, tell us.
If you didn't like
the tutor, tell us.
If you would rather have
individual office hours instead
of block office hours,
it's a good chance for you
to tell us what you think.
And it's especially
important that you fill out
the online subject evaluation.
So please, if you have a laptop
with a certificate on it,
feel free to bring it
to lecture next time.
That's one of the main ideas.
But we'll also spend
some time just discussing
what you would suggest for
improvements for next time.
Questions or comments?
OK, so today is
mostly just for fun.
Today is mostly just to
tell you about the way
6.003 plays out in
technologies that you
might have some interest in.
And I chose a technology that I
am particularly interested in.
Because as I probably have
mentioned in the past,
like many of you, I was
afflicted with an addiction
with music at about your age.
I recovered.
You will too.
But I was very interested in it.
It was a very hot topic.
And I want to talk about some
of the things that 003 has done
to make that industry very
different today from what it
was when I was an undergraduate.
It may not surprise
you, but it surprises me
that the technology that
we used was really not
very different
from the technology
that the inventor invented.
So who invented the phonograph?
You can look at the notes.
You're supposed to know that.
Just shout.
Makes me feel better.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Thank you--
Edison.
So Edison was, of course, a
genius and a prolific inventor.
At the time he invented
the phonograph,
he was interested in
two things that he
was trying to draw
relations between,
telegraphy and telephony.
We talked about
telegraphy before.
Telegraphy, telegraph, was
a way of getting messages
point to point.
So person A wanted to get
a message to person B.
And it would be transmitted
via the telegraph system.
Now I kind of
oversimplified the way
the telegraph
system worked when I
talked about it the last time.
It really worked a
lot more like message
passing than you
might have thought.
What would happen is
that there wouldn't
be a direct connection
between person A and person B.
It might have to go
through six relays.
So in order to
get to California,
it might be important
that a message that
originated in Boston
would go to New York,
and from New York
to Pennsylvania,
from Pennsylvania to
Chicago, et cetera.
So there may not be a direct
route over long distances.
So the way that was done,
you would take your message
to the telegraph office A.
The operator would key it in.
It would get written
down by the receiver,
say, in New York, who would
listen to the message,
write it out, basically
reproducing your message there,
then key it in to
the next relay.
So it might actually be
keyed in a dozen times
before it hits the
final destination.
And that was tedious,
laborious, hard.
And Edison was interested
in fixing that.
And to do so, he invented
a paper tape system,
so that the receiver
wouldn't need to listen it.
They would just punch out paper
tape as the clicks came in.
So as the dots and
dashes came in it,
it would make holes in paper.
The holes in paper,
then, could be
used to transmit to
the next station.
So Edison did that.
He was interested
in thinking about
whether you could do
the same sort of thing
with other kinds of signals
besides telegraph signals.
And that's the origin
of the phonograph.
He was interested in, could
you send a voice message
to a relay, have it
automatically recorded,
so that it could then be
rebroadcast over the next link?
So he was kind of imagining
a telephone network that
was based on the same principle
that the telegraph network had
been.
So the idea was to try
to record an audio signal
of the type that would come
across a telephone wire.
So he got together with
his aide, Batchelor,
and made this drawing.
This was 1877.
And 30 hours later--
kind of rapid prototyping
for the time--
his machinist made this.
So that's the first phonograph.
The idea was you wrap that
disk with a piece of wax paper.
You turn the crank.
As you turn the crank, this
thing is connected to a screw,
so that it's moving this way at
the same time this big thing is
going around that way.
This is a diaphragm, so
that you shout in here.
And there's a needle
connected on the other end,
so that as you shout,
the needle gets
moved with audio frequencies
contained in your voice.
So how do you do this, then?
So you grab the handle.
You put a new sheet
of wax paper on it.
You grab the handle.
You turn at a constant
speed, and shout.
OK, it took some coordination.
The remarkable
thing is it worked.
So Edison said, Mary
had a little lamb.
And on replaying it, the device
said, Mary had a little lamb.
The very first try, it worked.
Now it didn't work
all that great.
What do you suppose happened?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Noise?
Of course, there was noise, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Frequency was terrible.
Anything more disastrous?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Cranking
is not at all constant.
So you can make it sound like
Alvin the chipmunk if you like.
Something worse.
How long do you think
the recording lasted?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Yeah, about once.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So
the problem was,
to get the energy back
out, you have to--
so after recording-- so
clean sheet of wax paper,
crank, crank,
crank, yell, scream,
and now reset the
needle to the beginning.
And now crank without screaming.
In order to get the
message back out,
you had to push on the needle,
so that it would follow
the indentations on the wax.
But if you pushed hard
enough for it to follow it,
what would happen?
It would erase the message.
So it was kind of a
destructive read out.
It didn't last very long.
Because the act of reading it
back out tended to erase it.
So he redid the
thing with tinfoil.
That worked much better.
And in fact, it caught
on like overnight.
So within two years,
he was invited
to the National
Academies of Sciences
to give a talk on this.
That's him posing at the
National Academy of Sciences
with his then phonograph.
They loved it.
Now despite the
fact they loved it,
nobody knew what to do with it.
Everybody thought it was just
the neatest thing in the world.
But they didn't have a
clue what to do with it.
And of course, Edison, one,
was a bit self-promoting.
So he wrote articles about
it, and tried to explain.
In the patent, he listed
about seven or eight things
you could do with this thing.
Today they sound a
little far-fetched.
Recording important
historical addresses,
medical transcription--
the one that seems most--
I don't know-- sort
of gruesome to me,
recording the last will
and testament of a person
as they're dying.
Now that sounds gruesome to me.
Then imagine what it
was like back then.
Back then, nobody had ever
heard somebody's voice
who was not alive.
The technology didn't exist.
So all of the sudden,
he's proposing
to record the dying
breath of, say--
it kind of mortified everybody.
What Edison didn't
like was the idea
that it would be used for music.
That was trivial.
He was doing important science.
So he didn't like the idea that
this would be used for music.
And so he downplayed
that his entire life.
Nevertheless, the commercial
success was music.
He was trying to promote this as
a system for recording speech,
medical transcription, buying
breaths, historical talks.
That didn't really catch on.
This was a playback device.
This really did catch on.
This was about 60 years later.
It's virtually identical.
It became a piece of
furniture that everybody
had in their house.
The cylinders had
gone back to wax.
Alexander Graham Bell had
worked on the problem.
He figured out how to
make long-lasting wax.
This crank cranked a spring.
So you could crank it up,
but over time it would play.
So you didn't need to go
at exactly the right speed
anymore--
a number of big improvements.
The cylinders held two
minutes of recording.
So they weren't
exactly long-playing.
OK, this was the same model of
phonograph I had in college.
And it's actually
remarkably similar.
So there's some differences.
There was no crank.
We had electricity.
It had a motor.
So the motor propelled it.
It was no longer a cylinder.
Now it's a desk.
There was no screw.
So how does the needle track
the grooves if there's no screw?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
There's a spiral.
So the records had a spiral.
That's right.
This was the thing
that read the grooves.
What held that in the groove?
It was gravity.
So it was the same kind of idea.
You had to push on the needle to
hold the needle in the groove,
so that the needle could
report the vibrations that
were recorded there.
But this was much classier than
the version in Edison's time.
And in fact, you could tell
how serious the audio file was
by the different kinds of
performance enhancements
of this sort of thing.
So for example,
this little knob,
this controls the
weight, the force
that's placed on the needle.
If you had a good set
up, you could set it
for about 1.2 grams.
If you had a bad set up,
it'd go up to 2 grams.
So you could tell how serious
a person was by how much force
was required to track.
So for example,
the primary thing
that determined how
well the system worked
was the cartridge.
So here's a blow
up of a cartridge.
The cartridge--
anybody who is serious
had a diamond-tipped needle.
If they didn't have a
diamond-tipped needle,
you just didn't even
think about them.
So everybody I knew had
a diamond-tipped needle.
That was just the way it was.
The least expensive
kind of cartridges
was a little piece
of piezoceramic.
The piezoceramic
was stiff, so that,
as you played the records,
they tended to wear out.
Because you had to put
a lot of force on it.
Mine, I had the V15 type 4.
So this was a magnetic device.
So there were a tiny
little electromagnets,
so that the up and
down motions would
be converted into
an electrical signal
by magnetism, not by
piezoelectric effect.
And you could track that
with a much smaller force.
And I should just mention
just so you know that we
were serious back then--
so this cost 160 then dollars.
There's been a factor of six or
so inflation, this cost $1,000.
And if you were
serious, you had these.
So that's kind of the
technology as it existed
when I was an undergraduate.
And it was good.
It had existed for
over 100 years.
But it was still basically the
same thing Edison had done.
The media-- oh, I should
show it just in case
you've never seen a media.
So this is a record.
This was my record.
And the problem is, of
course, they scratch.
So over time, these
things would scratch.
So the technologies
for things like,
how do you keep them
from scratching,
how do you wear them out?
And you can also appreciate sort
of where the music industry is
coming from.
This costs about $15--
15 then dollars.
So with factor six,
it's about $100.
So from the point of
view of buying music,
it was much more
expensive back then.
And from the point of view
of the recording industry,
think of it.
You had all these
addicted people
wanting to buy this stuff.
And it wears out.
So you play it for
two or three years,
you have to buy a new one.
OK, so you can sort of
appreciate where the music
industry is coming from.
Because things have changed.
OK, so distortions, expensive,
fragile, blah, blah, blah.
Then in the 1980s,
everything changed.
In the 1980s, there was
the invention of the CD.
The CD was invented
by Philips Corp
and Sony Corp working together.
And just everything
was revolutionized.
So we'll talk a little bit
about how the CD works.
The important thing
for the discussion
is that, unlike records, CDs
are virtually indestructible.
They have very low distortion.
They are next to free.
And all of that is
technology that's
in large part enabled by 6.003.
Of And that's what I want
to actually talk about.
So what is a CD?
A CD is not very
different from a record.
So a CD has tracks.
The information is
written in tracks.
The tracks are
written as a spiral.
The spiral starts at the
inside and spirals out.
And so the idea is that you
read a spiral of messages.
And just like a record--
the way you make a record
is called embossing.
You make a master.
And then you take molten
plastic, and press it,
and copy the patterns
to make that record.
In fact, there is a big
technology on the formula
that you used for the vinyl.
One of the secrets of
RCA at the time when
I was in graduate school,
they had a secret recipe
that included dropping four
slices of American cheese
in their vinyl producing.
Because somebody had
accidentally once
dropped a sandwich.
And those records came out good.
So there were magical
things like that that
were trade secrets at the time.
OK, so that technology
was basically embossing.
And that's the same thing
you do when you make a CD.
CD is poly carbonate,
which is injection molded.
So you make a master.
The master is usually
made out of aluminum.
The master is made
very similar to the way
that Edison would make a master.
There's a big device
with an electromagnet
with a small stylus
and it punches them.
But then you copy the
CDs by injection molding.
So you take that original.
And there's actually
a complicated process.
You use the original to
make a half a dozen fathers.
The fathers are used
to make mothers.
Each father makes 20 mothers.
Then each of the
mothers make children.
And so you end up being
able to get a lot of copies
out of the original master.
There's a reflective
layer of aluminum
that's evaporated on top
of the polycarbonate.
And then there's a thin layer
of plastic put over the top.
That results in something
that's extremely robust.
And we'll see in a minute
how they make it robust.
But this dimension is
like over a millimeter.
So this is the CD version
of the same album.
So this surface is the
information reading side.
There's a millimeter
of stuff here.
There's a millimeter of
polycarbonate protecting
this surface that
has the information
from the environment.
So in fact, if you want
to destroy somebody's CD,
you might think the
way to do that would be
to write in felt tip on here.
No, don't do it that way.
Use a ballpoint
pen on this side.
Because that layer of
plastic is very thin.
So use a ballpoint pen here.
It will completely screw it up.
So it's very robust when it gets
imperfections on the read side.
OK, so that's kind
of the structure.
It's virtually
indestructible is the point.
So then, how do you get
the information on it?
Well, the information is
coded in these patterns.
The patterns are small.
The pattern width
is half micron.
A human hair is 50
to 100 microns thick.
And I have white here.
Well, I used to
have blonde hair.
I have gray here now.
Ignoring that for the moment,
I used have blond hair.
Blonde hair is about
50 microns diameter.
Black hair is about
100 microns diameter.
So depending on the
color of your hair,
it would obscure 30
to 60 tracks if you
were to lay a hair across it.
So these are very,
very small patterns.
And so the trick for how you
code them is a big problem.
Before we get there, though,
how do you code the audio?
You won't be too
surprised to find out
that it's a sample data system.
So we do sampling just the way
we've talked about it before.
Audio, you can hear
sounds from about 20 hertz
to about 20 kilohertz.
This is an ideogram.
Audiogram's plot is a
function of frequency.
What's the minimum
amplitude required
to be able to hear
that frequency?
You're most sensitive
in the kilohertz region.
The scale over here
is DB in something
we call sound pressure level.
Sound pressure level is
the centigrade equivalent
for hearing.
So 0 is just audible.
100 starts to hurt.
120 is permanent
damage kind of thing.
So you can hear about
100 decibels over a range
from 20 to 20 kilohertz.
And so the way they
coded it for the CD
was sampled at 44.1 kilohertz.
They chose that
funny number to be
a little bit bigger
than twice the highest
frequency that you can hear.
But they made it
the funny number
because they wanted it to
be an integer multiple of 60
so it was easy to synchronize
with television signals.
That's where the funny
number came from.
So 44.1 kilohertz divided
by 60 is some integer.
The problem is, of course,
that they wanted to be greedy.
They wanted all the
bits to code audio.
So they only sampled
barely over the frequency
that was required.
So according to the sampling
theorum, you need 40.
So if you had a sample
data system running at 44,
any amount of signal above 22
would alias and sound terrible.
So you need to put an
anti-aliasing filter
to prevent that.
We've kind of cheated the
whole way through 003.
We always said, when you
need a low-pass filter,
use an ideal one.
Well, they don't exist.
we use ideal filters because
they're conceptually simple.
There is no such thing.
If you actually try to make a
filter using designs like Russ
talked about in recitation.
Butterworth filters,
things like that, they
have transitioned bandwidths.
So there is a range
of frequencies
for which the filter is
neither fully on nor fully off.
And it's in transition.
You would like that range of
frequencies to be very small,
so you don't waste bandwidth.
So they would like to
reconstruct up to 40.
And they allowed 4
kilohertz in the guard band.
That was intentional,
because they
didn't want to have a
lot of bits that were not
useful for recording audio.
That's the reason they
only went up to 44, instead
of, say, 80, which would have
made the anti-aliasing problem
simple.
But it complicated the making
of the anti-alias filter.
Because there is sounds
that come into microphones
about 20 kilohertz.
It's just that you
can't hear them.
But if you were to record those
sounds, and then sample them
at 40 kilohertz, you
would hear the alias.
And it would be
highly objectionable.
So you have to anti-alias.
And that's actually hard.
Because if you'd like
to hear up to 20,
and if you're
sampling at 44.1, 20
reflected down to
24.1, which means
that you want the transition
band to be 34 kilohertz.
And if you think
about the design
of a filter like a
Butterworth filter,
in order to get a transition
that attenuates by ADDB--
think about the dynamic
range of hearing.
You have to make the
loudest sounds small enough,
so that you can no
longer hear them.
So in general, you have to
attenuate by about ADDB.
You need about 50 poles.
To get an ADD attenuation
using a Butterworth design
in 4 kilohertz at 20 kilohertz.
Everybody sort of know
what I'm talking about?
That's impossible.
Lining up filters-- so the way
the Butterworth filters work,
you remember?
So you have a bunch
of poles like so.
The way you think
about that is that you
start with a design that looks
like a not-so-good low-pass
filter.
Then you add these
poles, which give you
a peaky response like that, so
that when this is going down,
the peakiness here
helps to cancel that.
Then you do that again.
So you can think about
these successive pole pairs
as sharpening the
transition by pushing up
on the center frequency
and rolling off
on the edge frequency.
But in order for that to work,
they have to all be lined up.
So if you've got
50 of them, you've
got to be able to line these
up to about a percent or so.
Otherwise, they don't perform
the way they're supposed to,
and they can actually
make things worse.
So making an analog
filter of that type
was impossible then
and is difficult now.
Here is sort of the
state of the art.
So this actually does
have ADDB of roll
off, because it's
a fancier design.
As an elliptic design.
The trick here, though,
is that all the parts
are laser trimmed.
So they're all done
on one substrate.
All the inductors,
all the capacitors
are done on a single substrate.
Then they're laser trimmed,
so that they follow
the exactly the right places.
Then it's encased
in aluminum to help
to hold the temperature
constant and to keep
the electromagnetic
interference out.
And even so, this has
just 11 pole pairs.
So this is not nearly adequate
for that kind of a design.
So what we do instead is we use
something called oversampling.
So instead of sampling
at 44.1, which
is what you would think
would happen in a CD,
you sample it four times that.
By sampling at a
very high frequency,
you make it easy to make
an anti-aliasing filter.
Because now, you
only need to worry
about saving the frequencies
up to 20 kilohertz.
But you've got 170 kilohertz
to do the transition.
So the filter design
becomes very easy.
In fact, a typical design only
has five poles, and so just
a handful of capacitors.
Just two capacitors and
two op amps will do that.
So then you've got a system that
is sampled at 176 kilohertz.
What's the problem with that?
What's the problem with
sampling at 176 kilohertz?
Too much information.
So what you've done by sampling
at the higher frequency
is you've increased the amount
of information that needs
to be stored by a factor of 4.
So instead of being able to
record 74 minutes of music,
you can record 74 divided
by 4, 18 minutes of music.
Nobody would like that, right?
So how do you fix that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Downsample, exactly.
So what you do is you run
that discrete time signal that
was sampled at 176 through a
discrete low-pass filter, which
you implemented digitally with
arbitrary precision as much
as you want.
So here's a design based on
a filter whose length is 200.
By making a length 200
discrete time filter,
you can capture the
basic sine T over T shape
that you're trying to
get with an ideal filter.
So here with 200 samples,
it's easy to reproduce
a large number of ripples
similar to the large number
of ripples that I
wanted over here,
but now with digital
multiplies, not
with resistors and capacitors.
And this shows where the poles--
this is an all 0 filter.
It's a finite length filter.
We didn't talk about that.
It's an easy way to
implement filter design.
It's an easy way
to design filters.
It's a very popular
way of doing it.
So it's an all 0 filter.
And you can sort of
figure out by thinking
about the spacing of the
zeros relative to the unit
circle, how that implements
a low-pass filter.
That was done with an
automated optimizing
algorithm for finding
the best low-pass filter.
The method is called the
Parks-McClellan algorithm.
And it makes a very nice filter.
So this shows the
transition of ADDB
passing 20 kilohertz signals
and attenuating 24 and above.
So you get a very nice filter
by doing that in discrete time.
So then having done
the digital filter,
you can throw away
the frequencies
that would alias
and then downsample.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is the filter
in those zero locations
standardized by anybody?
Or does any manufacturer--
DENNIS FREEMAN: Any
manufacturer-- yes.
Every manufacturer is different.
What's happening
over time, though,
is that the chips are
becoming standardized.
So if you buy a particular chip,
it has a particular filter set.
But it's not
standardized in the code.
OK, so that's how you generate
a signal that is robust.
And it's basically just 003.
Now we have to think about,
how would you make the player?
Because what we'd
like to do is enable
you to use a CD in a
more portable fashion
than you could use
this technology.
So the question is
now, how would you
make a player that can pick up
this information off the CD,
so that you can
reproduce it in a Walkman
or in a more
portable environment?
So I had this brilliant
idea about two years ago
that I would take this CD and
I would use my microscope.
I may have mentioned
I light microscopy.
I went into my microscope.
I used my research-quality
microscope,
which costs $70,000.
And I'll take a beautiful
picture of the bits on here.
And I'll write a problem set
for 003 where you have to decode
the bitstream.
I thought it was brilliant.
And it was like a week
before the homework
had to be written, you
know, the standard thing.
And of course, I couldn't
get it to work in time.
The problem was that even my
$70,000 research microscope
has trouble seeing the bits.
The bits are really small.
So when I first tried it,
I couldn't see anything.
So I fiddled around
with the microscope.
I tried all different
kinds of magnifications.
I tried all kinds of
different optical tricks.
But I know I couldn't
figure out anything.
I couldn't get it to work.
So I got my graduate students.
They're always much better
at this sort of thing.
And we finally got it to work.
We cheated like crazy.
So we had to use something
called water immersion.
So you put a drop of
water on the surface,
so that you can use the--
you lose resolution when
you go through a glass
to air interface.
That's a bunch of microscopy
that you don't need to know.
But you do.
So there are tricks
in microscopy
where you can avoid having the
air interface by using water.
The water is more closely
optically matched to glass.
So what we did was we
did immersion microscopy,
put a drop of water on here,
put the lens in the water.
And that's the picture I got.
So the point is that I had
to work to get a $70,000
microscope to read
the bits off here.
And I sort of gave
up with the idea
that I would record a track.
Because it was just too painful
to just get this one image.
Now the trick is they make
players that cost $10.
What do they know
that I don't know?
So here I am with a
$70,000 research microscope
having a difficult time
getting the bits off.
How do they make a
CD player for $10?
Just for fun, I did the
same thing with a DVD.
After I figured out how to
do the immersion microscopy,
I figured I'd at least--
so this is a DVD done
with the same sort of thing.
So how do they do it?
They do very clever things.
The first trick they
use is interference.
So I talked about
interference last time
with our standing wave
illumination microscope.
They do interference.
So I told you that this is
polycarbonate with an aluminum
coding.
The aluminum is actually
working like a mirror.
And that's the intent.
So they don't actually try
to code block and white.
What they try to
code is distance.
So the idea is that
you take a laser beam,
and you out reflect
it off of the CD much
like it reflects off a mirror.
And then the features
that were embossed
are at different depths.
And the depth's chosen
very specifically
to be lambda over 4, the
wavelength of the light.
They use a 700 nanometer laser.
And the features are
offset by lambda over 4.
The idea is that--
so if you have a
feature, and you have--
so you compare, what would be
the timing for this laser beam
if it struck the mirror?
You compare that
to what it would
be if it struck a feature.
And you rig it so
that those two times
are different by lambda
over 2, lambda over 4 in,
and lambda over four out.
So then if you rig the beam
to be half of the light
falls on both, what's the
sum of these waveforms
going to be if you
have a component that's
at the mirror and a
component at the indented?
If these are different in
timing by lambda over 2
when you add them,
the answer is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yeah, you
get complete destructive
interference.
You get an out answer of 0.
So the idea in the
reading of them
is to use interference
and rig it
so that 0s are
represented by no light
and 1s are represented
by lots of light.
So that's the first
clever trick they do.
Then the question is,
how do you focus it?
When I was doing my research
microscope, the research
microscope-- and first off, it
sits on a half ton of granite
to make it all very stable.
Because when you're
doing the focusing,
you don't want--
so the vibrations
of the floor in my lab
are about 100 micrometers.
So it's about 100 micrometers.
And I have to have the stability
of the system sub-micron.
So I use a table made out
of a half ton of granite.
And the microscope
sits on top of that.
And that makes everything
nice and stable.
They can't do that.
So how do they control the
focus without using a half--
I mean, it wouldn't work
to make a Walkman that
is a half ton granite, right?
So what do they
do to enable them
to do the same kind of
focusing that I was doing?
They use feedback.
So the idea is to substitute
feedback for precision.
So rather than trying to
make the parts precise,
they put the imprecise
parts in a feedback loop--
very powerful method.
So here's what they do.
They take the laser.
It's trying to focus on to the
CD that has patterns in it.
And so there's a beam splitter,
so that part of the light
goes over to the detector.
Excuse me.
I didn't do that right.
The laser, it
squirts up to here,
goes straight through
the beam splitter,
comes back through
a focusing lens,
bounces off the beam splitter
through another lens,
and hits a detector.
So the detector is this way.
And I'm showing this view then.
So the detector should be there.
I'm sharing a view
of it over here.
And it's rigged, so
that these two lenses--
one of the lenses is spherical
and one is cylindrical.
What that means is--
you remember I've talked
about microscopy in the past.
Out of focus means blurred.
Blurred for a spot means bigger.
As a microscope goes out of
focus, the spot gets bigger.
What you do with
these two lenses--
because one is
circularly symmetric,
and the other is
slenderly symmetrical,
what you do is you make
the beam in this direction
go out of focus as it's going
into focus in this direction.
So because you get two lenses,
one is symmetric in xy.
And one has no magnification in
y, but big magnification in x.
You can rig it so that
this dot will go out
of focus horizontally while it's
coming into focus vertically.
The result is that, if you move
the CD closer, it becomes fat.
And if you move the CD
further, it becomes skinny.
So all they need to do,
then, is focus up and down
until the dot is
as close to being
circular as they can get it.
That's why they use
a quadrant detector.
So the quadrant detector
lets them calculate
a plus c minus b plus d.
And you would like
that answer to be 0.
So now you use
that as your error.
They use the light that
hits this quadrant detector
to compute this number,
put that in a feedback loop
that drives the stage
up and down to focus.
So here's an ancient CD.
The CD would be here.
Here is the reading lens.
Here is a platform that has
an electromagnet under it that
will move it up and
down 100 microns.
So this electromagnet
is under the stage.
So this whole thing
goes up and down
in a feedback loop that
tries to make this error
signal be 0, tries to make the
pattern circularly symmetric.
So it's extremely clever.
Then you have this pattern.
So the light is twice as big.
Half the photons are
supposed to fit in the pit.
And half of the
photons are supposed
to hit in the land
that surrounds the pit,
so that as the CD is spinning,
if the spot illuminates
a place that's
entirely in the pit,
the dot is small
because of interference.
And if it hits a place
that doesn't have a pit,
the dot is large, because
there's no interference.
But then you have
the problem of,
how do you keep the dot reading
the center of the groove?
So in this technology,
we kept the dot
in the center of the
groove by using gravity.
We obviously don't want
to touch that surface.
So that's not the
technology we use.
We don't use a screw.
We use feedback.
So here what we do, instead
of projecting a single dot,
we use a beam
splitter that turns
the one dot into three dots.
And the three dots
are positioned
so that they hit two
more photo sensors, one
on each side of the
main photo center.
And the idea is that, if the
light is perfectly centered
on a track, these will
have equal brightness.
But now if the beam is off
center, one of the dots
will be bright, because
it hit all land, compared
to the other one, which some of
the light is hitting the pit.
So this is just like the
head tracking thing in 601.
So whichever of the two photo
sensors gets more light,
you move the track to
compensate for that.
So it all works in
a feedback loop.
So the idea here is
the same sort of deal.
You have two sensors here.
And you use the error, which is
the difference between the two,
to move the head to the track.
And the head motion is
this thing over here.
So here's a rack and pinion
connected up to a motor.
And so you have that
motor servo-ed back
to some photo sensors over here
that keep the beam centered.
So the idea, then, is
that what you get for $10
to read this thing is
completely remarkable.
The idea is that it's got very
complicated servo mechanisms
that can read very small
things that even a $70,000
microscope has trouble reading.
And it's stable.
And you can run them, or
you can jostle them around,
and jog with them.
And that's all because they use
feedback, rather than trying
to make precision machining.
And then they make the
signals robust by using
the kind of DT signal
processing that we talked about.
So anyway, the point
of today was just
to give it some motivation
of the way 6.003 factors
into technologies that you
might be interested in.
And this is just one example.
I could have chosen any
number of different devices
and they would
have been similar.
So I hope you
enjoyed the course.
I hope that you have
fun with the final.
Please come on
Tuesday, and tell us
what we should do
differently next time.
Thanks.